ya son al menos 600.000 las hectáreas
quemadas en Europa desde el mes de enero
con la temporada alta de incendios
todavía en curso debido a las altas
temperaturas y las olas de calor datos o
proporcionados por el sistema europeo de
información sobre incendios forestales
es que elaboraba las estadísticas a
comparables desde 2006 gracias a las
imágenes satelitales del programa
europeo copérnicus la zona más golpeada
por los incendios ha sido la Península
ibérica En España se quemaron
246.278 hectáreas principalmente en las
regiones de Galicia y la provincia
castellana de Zamora y extremadura en
Portugal son 17.000 las hectáreas que se
quemaron en el parque natural Serra da
estrella y en Francia 2022 ha sido el
peor de los últimos 16 años en gran
medida causa de los grandes incendios
sucesivos en el departamento de gironda
y Reino Unido declaró oficialmente el
estado de ezequía en varias zonas de
Inglaterra saludamos entonces Andrew
escrivá él es a juego y doctor en
biodiversidad de Andrew Gracias por
estar con nosotros en directo América de
Francia 24 Qué tan grave entonces esta
situación en Europa en cuanto a las
horas de calor y también la implicación
que esto ha tenido en un senset de los
incendios en los ecosistemas y en los
bosques
Hola Buenos días Pues la verdad es que
tiene una implicación muy directa es
decir Europa está viviendo el verano más
cálido de su historia estamos batiendo
récords Día tras día España ha
experimentado La ola de calor más
intensa y más larga de toda su historia
y esto lo que hace es poner digamos en
jaque y de poner un escenario de
muchísima fragilidad a unos ecosistemas
que ya estaban soportando estos impactos
del cambio climático pensemos que el
verano es cuando menos llueve aquí y
además hace mucho calor con lo cual las
plantas ya están muy estresadas tenemos
mucha masa forestal que pueda arder en
cualquier momento y lo que ha pasado
desgraciadamente es esto que tras muchos
muchos días de sequedad El Monte estaba
preparado para arder y ha sucedido en
varios puntos de forma simultánea lo
cual encima a dificultado su extinción
no Entonces estamos viviendo Un verano
histórico que no podría explicarse de
ninguna manera sin el cambio climático y
que desgraciadamente lo que nos muestra
es que las previsiones del cambio
climático acertaban pero se han quedado
cortas estamos viendo lo que se suponía
que íbamos a ver de aquí 10-15 años o
sea que podemos esperar digamos peores
incendios en los próximos años y también
más altas temperaturas el Le quiero
preguntar si también pues en la
naturaleza Digamos si actuamos ya se
puede recuperar digamos estos bosques y
que no haya tanta sequía en Europa sobre
todo no
Pues sí afortunadamente tenemos
herramientas para hacer una gestión
forestal sostenible tenemos herramientas
para restaurar ecosistemas para re
salvajizar ecosistemas para hacerlos más
resilientes no para adaptarlos a este
escenario nuevo que es el cambio
climático Entonces no todo está perdido
ni mucho menos lo que tenemos que ser
conscientes es de dónde estamos y no
podemos usar las mismas herramientas que
estábamos usando hace 20-30-40 años con
lo cual las previsiones desgraciadamente
se han cumplido Pero eso no significa
que tiremos la toalla Tenemos la
oportunidad de adaptar estos ecosistemas
de ceder espacio a la naturaleza Europa
tiene muchas partes muy construidas
cerca de ríos en la costa etcétera que
necesitamos devolver a la naturaleza
para darle ese espacio para que se
recupere no Entonces sí que se está
abogando por por esta visión mucho más
moderna de cómo gestionar los
ecosistemas y sobre todo hay que pensar
que no todo es cambio climático las
altas temperaturas son un factor en los
incendios pero se explican también por
muchas otras cuestiones entre ellas la
ocupación del territorio con lo cual yo
espero que se tome buena nota y que a
partir de ahora Europa se pongan muy en
serio con los incendios que se pensaba
que solo nos afectaba los países del sur
como España no y que hemos visto como
como han dicho antes que también están
afectando a Francia a Reino Unido
Alemania etcétera etcétera claro estos
incendios también van acompañados con la
sequía porque ya varios países digamos
han declarado alertas por estos bajos
niveles de agua incluso lagos que han
desaparecidos debido a la evaporación no
del agua como esto también afecta a
nuestro entorno no
claro la sequía de hechos es otro de
estos fenómenos no que se pensaba que en
Inglaterra no podía pasar lo que en
Alemania no podía pasar hay barcos que
ya no pueden navegar por Alemania por
algunos de los ríos por el ring en
Inglaterra están con restricciones de
uso de agua están prohibidas las
mangueras en Francia también es decir
tenemos un escenario que no pensábamos
ver y que además viene después de unas
altísimas temperaturas en Inglaterra
recordemos que han batido su récord
histórico 40 grados por primera vez en
la historia desde que hay registros no
con lo cual esta sequía lo que lo que
pone en jaque también es esa
Independencia también energética porque
en el caso de Francia al no haber agua
con la que refrigerar algunas centrales
nucleares han tenido que parar es decir
no es únicamente una cuestión de los
ecosistemas de las plantas de la fauna
sino que está poniendo el sistema
económico y lo que estamos viendo Es que
el agua es un bien esencial que tenemos
que empezar a considerar como tal Y no
como un recurso ilimitado como parece
que en algunas partes considerando
además que ya el agua está escaseando en
varios lugares del mundo Android le
quería preguntar Europa digamos de dónde
también puede sacar estos recursos
hídricos que vemos que ya pues le
empiezan a hacer falta
Pues yo creo que afortunadamente tenemos
mucho muchísimo potencial de ahorro como
en otras partes del mundo el primer la
primera pérdida de agua se produce a
veces en las propias tuberías en las
canalizaciones en la forma de regar que
no es la más eficiente entonces creo que
Europa tiene muchísimo potencial de
ahorro por ejemplo donde yo vivo en
Valencia que es la región mediterránea
de España hemos avanzado muchísimo los
últimos años porque hemos tenido este
problema otros países como Inglaterra
como Francia como Países Bajos Alemania
no han tenido este problema y por lo
tanto han pospuesto esta toma de medidas
yo creo que de ahí vamos a poder sacar
mucha agua de esa gestión responsable y
luego quedan alternativas puntuales como
Puede ser desalinizaciones Es decir
agua del mar del mar perdón y
quitarle la sal que esto puntualmente
para algunos usos muy urgentes puede
tener sentido Pero desde luego no es la
solución a gran escala claro también
digamos hablando de agua y calor en
España por ejemplo decenas de peces
centenares de peces se han muerto por el
aumento de las temperatura grasa en los
males también como esto afecta el
ecosistema Marino tan importante además
también recordemos que de los mares es
donde pues se produce el mayor oxígeno
del planeta pues justamente esos me
parece una cuestión interesantísima
porque muchas veces hablamos de ola de
calor en la tierra donde vivimos en las
ciudades en los campos pero también hay
olas de calor en el Mar el mar
Mediterráneo de hecho acaba también de
superar su
récord absoluto de temperaturas hemos
medido temperaturas superiores a los 30
grados cerca de valencia y cerca de las
Islas baleares con lo cual lo que
tenemos es una ola de calor en el mar un
incendio en el mar esto afecta a la
fauna afecta a las praderas de posidonia
que es esta planta que digamos de alguna
forma alimenta toda la vida en el
Mediterráneo está afectando a la pesca
pero también está afectando a los
turistas y está afectando a que de
pronto hay muchas medusas que se
aprovechan de esta situación excepcional
y lo que tenemos es una bomba de
relojería porque un mar tan caliente
tiene mucha energía y es capaz cuando
venga otoño de aquí un par de meses de
generar probablemente lluvias
torrenciales que también afecten Pues a
estos Montes a estos ecosistemas
forestales que acaban de sufrir
incendios no se retroalimenta y tenemos
que ir con mucho cuidado y tener siempre
en consideración en el mar no no dejarlo
nunca fuera de la ecuación